[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 71 of
the weekly Google clappa from podcast I
am Francis Campo and I'm here with my
colleague Mark Mandel hey Mark how are
you doing I'm good thanks Frank says how
are you doing today Brigid very happy uh
uh pretty feeling lonely where are you I
am in Vancouver it's cold here
I left sunny San Francisco to come to
Vancouver
yeah yeah that that would teach you
anyway today we're going to have a
pretty cool episode we have one of our
dear developer advocates from our team
at Google cloud platform you think whoa
to talk about the cloud machine learning
engine yeah he's going to come have a
chat with us about tensorflow machine
learning how to do it in the cloud how
can you use it what is this crazy thing
that's it's a very interesting topic and
the cool thing is that basically makes
tensorflow
like basically as a service you don't
need to have to install anything it's
just it's there so it's very very useful
yeah and if you have huge datasets it's
very very useful
oh yeah especially for that yeah awesome
and then after that we're gonna have our
question of the week which I think
you're gonna know a whole lot about
we're going to talk about API keys and
cloud endpoints when do I need them when
do I want them yeah it's a pretty common
question so hopefully will be pretty
useful for lots of people but before
that I think we have today a bunch of
different cool things of the week the
first one coming from you you are the
kubernetes 1.6 and I don't know much
about what's new in kubernetes 1.6 so
why don't you tell us a little bit sweet
so criminales 1.6 I am a huge
community's fan as many people know
there is a huge amount of stuff going on
in 1.6 which is great a huge huge scale
increase which i think is really cool
we're up from two thousand nodes
supports to five thousand nodes and
150,000 node supports overview at a high
level there is new stuff around security
there's a whole bunch of advanced
scheduling features storage provision
and more there's some pretty cool stuff
going on if you want to know more about
it go to the coop entities blog they're
doing five days of kubernetes 1.6
they're up to day 3 currently of all
deep dives into all the new stuff
they've covered dynamic privilege
Jenning some scalability updates
advanced scheduling day four and five
don't know what's coming but pretty
excited to see what's coming cool maybe
we should have someone from the
kubernetes team to tell us a little bit
about all the new things absolutely we
should totally do that and we have then
one more cool thing I'm going to go with
that one which is I'm a big fan of
Google App Engine and one of the flavors
of App Engine is App Engine flexible
environment and the new thing is that is
now available in Europe West region so
if you've ever tried to run node or Ruby
or any of those languages that run on
App Engine flex so yeah now if you if
you're one of those people that run Ruby
or node and you want to run them on App
Engine flex you can now run them in your
West which means that if you have
customers in there you have a way
shorter latency which is always a nice
thing to have awesome now super excited
to have that in the region I'm sure
there's plenty people in Europe and
surrounding areas who are very excited
as well well so finally cool things of
the week I just want to say a quick
shout out to one of the gentlemen who
joined us on the podcast of the
community summit 3 on next I'm probably
going to Massacre his name Kell of
litter ooh I think I got that vaguely
right he wrote a series of articles for
Forbes magazine that were forbes online
talking about google cloud next his
experiences and what his views and his
viewpoints are it's fairly long but
there's some really cool and interesting
content in there where he talks about
security scale learning as a service
much like what we're talking about today
lots of really good stuff yeah we'll
have links through every single one of
the three articles that he wrote
nonetheless three articles on the show
notes so if you're interested in going
there just go check it out and have a
long and nice week excellent so why
don't we go talk to you Frank I am very
happy today to welcome to the podcast
one more of our dear fellow developer
advocates you think well how are you
doing I'm great thank you and we have
you here to talk about many things but
mostly machine learning but before we
start doing that why don't you tell us a
little bit about yourself and what you
do I google sure so I'm like you guys a
developer advocate on the Google cloud
team
and lately I've been focusing on a lot
of machine learning stuff and what that
means is on the cloud side I've been I'm
talking about and playing with the cloud
machine learning engine which recently
went GA and also as a corollary to that
a lot of work with tensorflow
awesome so we said a little products
there but this is probably a very big
question but what is machine learning
hmm yeah so machine learning the the
what is it question is definitely a big
one that kind of everybody's wondering
right now and in general I my short
version of what is machine learning is
it I define it with five or six words
it's using examples to answer questions
or answering questions using many
examples so I think that's five words so
then all and I've distilled it down to
that you know so all the words are kind
of important
using you want to answer questions we're
not just using machine learning for the
sake of it right it's the purpose of it
is to answer the questions that you have
and then we want to use examples to do
that so that means you need to have
examples to show your system and you
need lots of them so okay so questions
you saw instead of basically like
writing an algorithm what you do is you
just throw data' at something like this
is how you're supposed to do it in the
machine learning that the machine
learning part of it right and another
way to kind of visualize that is to
think of traditional programming as you
writing a bunch of rules you can think
them almost like the flow of a river
right so the information flows from the
top of your program downwards goes to
different functions flows through if
statements and for loops and then the
output of your various functions in your
program is something right so a machine
learning algorithm is kind of doing the
same thing with data you're writing you
creating some structure and all this
data is flowing throughout all this math
is happening and then on the other side
of that there's some output but there's
this additional step beforehand where
you need to write
ode to make that something were the data
flow so you need to make the structures
that the data will flow through in the
first place whereas with normal
programming that is your code
interesting so given all of that context
where is denser flow right so tensor
flow then is an open source library that
Google released a little over a year ago
in November of 2015
and it's an open source library written
at its core in C++ and C and then has a
Python API and now a couple api's and
other languages there's a go there's a
go binding yes and so that's a library
for facilitating the creation of these
the structures that we were talking
about earlier that the data would flow
through we call them graphs cool so all
right say I'm like yes machine learning
and tend to flow but I don't know where
to apply it what is some common or like
regular type things that people who tend
to do with machine learning that people
could then apply it themselves so the
two or three big categories of use cases
that we're seeing emerge is image
classification data structured data
classification or regression and finally
something to the effect of time series
so whether it's streaming log data or
videos or audio that the time series
where you care about the previous data
points those are kind of the three broad
categories that we're seeing
so when you say classification what does
that actually mean though just so people
understand and understand right so
classification is where you put the data
into kind of different buckets different
categories if you will and you could
have as few as two categories and in
that those two could even be is it X or
is it not X it doesn't necessarily have
to be x and y right it could be like I'm
recognizing these pictures as apples or
other doesn't necessarily have to be
apples or bananas and so the
classification has also emerged as this
place where you end up being able to put
a lot of problem sets into like you can
fit
a lot of problems into the domain of
classification quote-unquote because you
can also go from not just two classes
but many many classes so you can say
have a hundred classes or even a
thousand classes so then you begin to
get into a situation where you're able
to bucket things into many many
different buckets and that can also be
very powerful can you give an example of
like when you're saying like thousand
buckets what kind of application would
do that
so one one classic example is the
imagenet competition which is an
international machine learning
competition for image recognition so
they provide a thousand categories that
you as the machine learning scientist or
the competitor need to create a machine
learning model which will classify the
input data the pictures into the correct
one of these thousand categories so if
you get a picture of a specific breed of
dog that might be a particular category
or bucket in those thousands interesting
so what about when you have something
that is not really I'd say it's probably
not a classification problem gives
rather than having a bunch of buckets um
however many you might have it is
something continuous like I don't know
like it's something you're trying to
predict a value and it's a float so you
know there's infinite technically and
also not technically not but whatever
absolutely and so that is what is
typically referred to as regression so
that's the other side of this particular
subset problems where you you're trying
to predict the value one example that
kind of treads the line is let's say you
had a machine learning model that took a
bunch of inputs such as your diet when
you want to sleep like just lots of
these quantified self and tracking
variables and try to predict your age
okay I thought you're gonna say try to
predict the day you die is that this is
the same thing it's a [ __ ] is that
I'm pretty sure the date you died that's
that's probably just a random generator
X time in the future so with that it
what's tricky about it is do if you just
output a number like an integer number
do you count that as regression or
classification because yeah there are a
lot of ages right one through something
on the order of 100 but as we said you
know you could pretty easily classify
between 100 different things and maybe
you say well I don't think I can be as
precise as to say like you know your age
is you know thirty five point seven or
something like that yeah but at the same
time maybe you don't even want to be as
specific as saying it's 35 so then you
get into saying bucketing into different
age groups and saying okay you're in the
18 to 25 age group and you gotta see
that like think about like surveys and
things like that and it's a operating
symbol so there's basically like there's
classification problems there's
regression problems and then something
can in the middle where you could choose
going one way or the other out of all of
those problems treatable wave tensorflow
absolutely absolutely intense flow is
really meant to be a general-purpose
machine learning library and it's
actually in some ways broader than that
because all its really doing is creating
this graph that we talked about earlier
where all the numbers flow through and
you can create that to do anything you
want you can have it do math just like
addition or multiplication and then
compute you know other kind of more
complicated math things that are not
machine learning in that thing that you
said yeah the high level tooling around
it that says like you know just make
this thing for me that's all geared
toward machine learning but if you go
into it and you use some of the low
level tooling where you can really
control the graph and build it kind of
from scratch piece by piece you can
build anything you want cool so I got a
question like so Americans are curious
so we've seen examples like you said
like where image classification it's a
classification problem but like Francis
talked about Martin's talk last last
episode and in that he was generating
stuff out of models that he'd put
tensorflow to like basically making
things sound like Shakespeare or
Shakespearean like text where does that
kind of sit where it's like your general
stuff to seem like similar other things
is that like predictive or what's the
deal there yeah absolutely
so the these generative models is kind
of a new newish class of machine
learning algorithm machine learning
models and part of it is mapped to the
kind of traditional things that we were
talking about where you have this model
in this particular case you're taking
all the works of Shakespeare and putting
it running it through the model so that
the output is this model that can kind
of recognize whether something is or
isn't Shakespeare okay okay so that you
could give it some new text and then it
will think of a run it through and then
on the other side I will say yes this is
Shakespeare or no it's not Shakespeare
now in doing that you've basically
created a little system that can also
generate Shakespeare and that it knows
what Shakespeare is like right it's
encoded into that model and so then if
you can massage it in the right way you
can also have it output what it thinks
Shakespeare would be and another another
way to kind of think about that or the
design that would be to say give it
Shakespeare and have it learned this is
more of that sequencing model we're
going to the third kind of class where
you're looking at a sequence of words so
with Shakespeare you have write any
writing that's a sequence of words so
you teach it to say okay I know that
after the word a usually there's either
words B 1 B 2 or B 3 and then it's like
C 1 C 2 herbs you know these words and
so these are like the possible sequences
so given some input it can kind of
continue and that's the exact same idea
and basis for some of the audio models
that we see like the music related ones
where you can play the first few notes
and then it picks up for you it's it's
just analyzing the data that's embedded
in a music signal whether that's just
straight audio or like something like
MIDI all right cool all right so we've
talked about tensorflow for the open
source project let's talk about cloud
machine learning engine and like what is
that thing so can you tell us like
what's the difference or what is what is
the cloud machine learning engine
from a high level so the cloud machine
learning engine is really at its core
managed infrastructure for running
tensorflow on the Google cloud platform
and so we'll break down each of those
points the part about it being managed
infrastructure the difference there is
it's not that you need to spin up some
virtual machines allocate some storage
or persistent disk and then tell it oh
here's where I want you to run the
things right it will do that for you it
will spin up the machines it will make
sure the right libraries are installed
etc and so you have this managed
infrastructure and then you then just
have to give it your tensorflow code and
we have the G cloud command line tool
that will take care of that for you as
well the code goes up and then the
machines are automatically created for
you spun up and the code your code is
loaded in and then it runs it for you
and then when it's done that output goes
to Google Cloud storage where your data
was as well and so you can define all
those parameters including how many
machines how powerful you want those
machines to be whether those machines
should have a GPU attached to them etc
but at the end of the day your the code
now you write the machine learning code
is just pure tensorflow code cool so you
mentioned the output what is the output
is that the prediction that you make or
what what is it usually the in the first
half of kind of the work that you do
which is your training the output of
that is the model itself so that's just
a file or a few files that together
define that graph of basically that math
mathematical kind of model that can take
an input and generate the desired output
usually prediction ok so that's what all
the people also got like the like a
neural network itself that is that what
we're talking about exactly so in the
case of a neural network that file would
just be lots and lots of numbers right
in its path down into a binary format
and you know you can pass in a picture
and it'll tell you is a kitten or puppy
right cool and so that first
step is just half of the machine
learning engine in that that's the
training half and the other half of
machine learning is the answering of
questions and so to facilitate that you
have the prediction service so that's
what I view is another large chunk of it
that is often overlooked because so much
emphasis is placed on the training
because it is the more challenging half
by and large but after you've gathered
all your data cleaned it pick the right
model tuned its parameters spend who
knows how long training it and waiting
for it to finish the last thing you want
to be doing is then going and looking up
on Stack Overflow how exactly do I spin
up a web server to wrap this model to
scale that server logging quotas all the
good stuff especially for someone who is
well versed in machine learning you know
that tends to be your data scientist or
you know machine learning researcher
there they are oftentimes not as
experienced in managing infrastructure
right they might not because they're
spending all the time in kind of machine
learning land they're not over here
learning about kubernetes and docker and
scalable systems and things like that
though the prediction service helps you
with that it says just give us the model
that folder with the couple files that
was output from your training and it
gives you like a rest endpoint or
something like that exactly it gives you
a scalable rest endpoint that just is
deployed for you and it also takes care
of versioning so that you can say okay
I'm going to make a model my puppies or
kittens model and this is going to be v1
and then later when you train a new
model you can say this is v2 and you'll
have both of them and you can switch
between them as like which one's default
it's like App Engine and endpoints
merged together for machine learning
yeah that's pretty cool yeah so so I
think that that's a really neat feature
in that those two steps are decoupled
thanks to tensor flow in that you have
this models file model file output which
means that if you do local training you
output that same exact file because
cloud machine learning engine is just
running tensorflow
the outputs of training in the cloud and
outputs of training
are pretty much the same it's just the
question of do you want it to be
distributed do you want it to be faster
and so that output then you can just
push or upload those files to the cloud
yourself and then put it to the
prediction engine so you could train
locally and predict on you know in a
scaleable on the cloud so I see the
value of serving that those models that
prediction on the cloud because you know
you want people to access it what is the
benefit of training on the cloud rather
than training on your own laptop that's
a really good question
so when training on the cloud there are
a couple reasons you might want to do it
on both sides right if you're just
working with a small data set and you
know you're okay you're okay with the
performance on laptop and by all means
training you laptop train on your
desktop training on your local GPU
cluster if you have one right but when
you get into situations where your data
sizes are too big to be stored on your
one division like weather and that that
can be a number of different thresholds
because you know if you if I just have
my laptop here on my laptop maybe it
just has one terabyte of disk and so
something less than a terabyte but more
than a couple hundred gigs I probably
don't want to be you know wrangling that
around maybe what I'll do though is take
a section I'll take a representative
sample of that data put down on my
laptop and train that locally so I can
get the code working correctly
that's a nice and fast iteration cycle
it's like your development cycle is on
the computer right but then when you
actually train you will not turn on your
computer because it's just low or so
usually if yeah if your data set is
really quite large it can be too slow
what's what is large yeah what's give us
can you give us a rule of thumb I know
obviously ballpark figures ish but like
where would you say that line would be
in terms of we call may vary how many
kittens versus puppies are we talking
about here yeah yeah because and before
before I try to come up with a number
here there's there's so many other
parameters that play around that data
because it depends on how big your
network is that you're trying to Train
how big are these images that you're
pushing in right whether or not you're
going to downsample them to a lower
resolution will also make a big
difference and then finally just your
general hardware and
ops configurations around transfer speed
so a lot of times you end up with
situations where your i/o bound
sometimes its compute bound and then
sometimes it's kind of like memory bound
just like shuffling things around there
are situations where people have had to
move to distributed CPUs because the
data could not fit on the six gigs or
twelve gigs of RAM on the GPU card oh
wow okay
like they had to hold all that at once
I'm not saying that the whole data set
was big in that because of course a lot
of times they are but like for the
computation yeah yeah yeah hold you know
over 6 or 12 gigs of data it's like
that's crazy so you didn't answer the
question so nicely done from your hip
very good very very developer advocate
but so give us a one of one concrete
example that you've done how big was the
data and and how long it took to Train
on your laptop or how long it took to
train a flat amount engine so the one
good example of that was when I was
training a transfer learning model for
this is actually I was running through
one of our code labs but it was for um
for a niche model for recognizing five
different types of flowers and that is
more than I can they were there were
like common flowers like roses and
tulips are giveaways and things like
that so that data set was um I think
believe it was a couple hundred thousand
images images images and training
locally on my CPU it was taking on the
order of like half an hour okay so it
was like getting to the point where I
was like well I don't really want to be
burnt you know taking just I can't use
my browser it's slow it's burning
through my battery the fan is spinning
and so pushing that to the cloud I was
able to it was coming down to not
including kind of spin up time and and
that the other thing about what we'll
get into it was taking about like 15 ish
minutes so the half but there was like
not like that powerful wood
configuration you know I think it was
just like a basically a fanzine desktop
and so moving from a laptop to a fancy
desktop you know
got some boost but no nothing crazy I
think the the crazy scaling factors
happen when you have truly tremendous
datasets um you know maybe on the order
of era yeah possibly terabytes like
hundreds of gigs to to you know multiple
terabytes worth of data or en and up and
the data size is really hard number to
really just go against because if you
have image data it's bigger and if you
have log files it'll be smaller you know
you can fit a lot of log files in ten
thousand JPEGs and then those log files
are rich data and so pushing that all
through and if it's a complex model can
also take a long time so it's a it's not
a you know easy kind of rule of thumb
cool so I'm curious about
so tensorflow Waddy days is an open
source library right yeah um it is not
the only one I'm assuming uh what is
like could you give a little bit of a
comparison what you use tends to flow
rather than something else and I
personally don't know any other so so
I'm going to let you answer that
question completely
so with tensorflow
advantages there I think are primarily
around the ability to go from research
to production easily in the past and in
a lot of other fields as well where you
have research and production is kind of
separate parts of the industry you you
end up with a situation where the
research is doing things in one language
or writing their own custom frameworks
and then to implement it to make it run
fast you rewrite everything in C++ or
Tahoe and what's great about tensorflow
is that the underlying implementation is
already in C++ but you get to work on it
via Python or in your case go I have not
tried ID yet but yeah so that allows you
to have flexibility while maintaining
high performance and one of the things
in the tensorflow 1.0 release which came
out in February 15th is the release of
Excel a which is still experimental and
it stands for accelerated linear
our algebra and I know everybody loves
talking about linear algebra but in a
nutshell what it does is it takes your
trained graph or model and think about
compiling that down so instead of
representing it with C++ it actually
represents it with machine code so it
makes it another another layer exactly
another layer of optimization so instead
of running a compiler on your code right
think about compiling a code and now
it's really fast right what we're going
to do is we're going to compile the
graph which you know in our analogy is
kind of the code that's what the data is
flowing through we can compile that down
to machine code or something like
machine code so that the data can run
through even faster well that is pretty
amazing that is very cool I'm curious
now so as well what's been the most
interesting or crazy or wonderful
machine learning thing that you've seen
people do with either tenth of low or
machine I mean I have an answer to that
question chip but you go first sounds
good so I think one of the most relevant
and in terms of real-world applications
of pushing and learning that I've seen
is the recent research that came out
around skin cancer and diabetic
retinopathy retinopathy detection and
there's there's many groups doing
similar work for other areas of Medicine
as well because this is these are areas
where you have a task that is highly
sophisticated but well-defined and
repeatable and right now is limited to
the kind of domain of trained experts
who are human and thus subject to
tiredness sleepiness grumpiness things
like that and so having a machine that
can at least do that initial first pass
for you is great it's more like you
don't have a traffic cop standing at
every single intersection waiting for
someone to run up that red light you
have a camera it will flag them for you
and then maybe you have a human at the
end of the chain that says like oh no
that was fine he was turning on a red or
something like that but you know it
helps you give that first pass and so in
the example with skin cancer you have
very good detection rates that are
actually comparable to professionals but
even if you didn't even for the
where it's not perfect I think it would
be interesting to see like because image
recognition and computer vision are kind
of more advanced than some other areas
of machine learning right now it would
be really interesting to see those
applications in places where it's not as
perfect as long as you can have a human
in the chain because if it's not perfect
and you're making a lot of mistakes then
it can lead to bad experience and I
guess also it gets interesting to where
we're personnel on ground is probably
less hard
less less easy to get to or able to
reach to and so if you can make that
first pass in a way that can be
automated or something like that yeah I
can't imagine if you were able to create
basically a like mobile app that
anywhere in the world can use I give you
a doctor that doesn't have access to
that training that is pretty amazing
absolutely and in certain you know
countries around the world there are
certain types of doctors that are in
super high demand and you have just
lines going down the street around the
corner and they only come every once in
a while and you know they can't even see
everybody in time so and then you can
imagine like the quality of care and
those kind of scenarios were just kind
of turning through everybody is it's not
going to be very high cool
you had something what was it Francis
yeah my answer is way more lame but it's
my answer is actually one of our
colleagues she used to be a developer
advocate Julia Farrelly she gave a
really good talk on hugga hugga ball or
not which basically was a machine it was
a neural network trained with a bunch of
images and telling telling that either
it was huggable like you should hug it
or not and and the coolest buyers like
it shows an octopus
it's like you should not have an octopus
and then it shows like a little plush
it's like you should checked you should
definitely hug the plush and then it
showed plush octopus and machine
learning algorithm was actually able to
tell that yeah you should definitely hug
a octopus plush look oh that is really
cool so yeah you know it's like it's not
saving lives but I thought it was pretty
cool yeah I mean blend blending this
kind of knowledge and generalizing to
examples that it hasn't seen before is
one of the strengths of machine learning
especially in the area of deep learning
you're building something that is
generalizing beyond just like memorizing
things yeah so we're kind of running out
of time and I'd like to give you the
opportunity to give us anything else
that you have is there anything else I
do like to mention we recently hired
philately from oh yeah from Stanford and
and she she's just awesome yeah I
believe the exact quote from next was
she is another badass woman she's a
badass woman yeah so and and so between
that and the recent acquisition of Kegel
it really feels like there's have this
gathering forces and within Google and
and within the community that is kind of
propelling the machine learning
community forward and creating an
ecosystem where people can get started
quickly can run their systems cheaply
fast and have the support that they need
to grow and interact with their peers
so like the kaggle acquisition really
helps further a platform that you know
is or has already gained a lot of
traction I cago is definitely kind of
the place for data scientists and data
sets to live and having that be in a
position to continue to grow and be kind
of funded and not go away is really
fantastic things you mentioned them if
anyone from Kaggle wants to come to the
podcast they're definitely invited and
if they fail you're listening to this we
were definitely definitely invited you
definitely definitely invited so please
please what do you know how to reach us
so thank you so much for your time you
think that was a very interesting
conversation
yeah thank you franceska mark this was
great thanks thanks so much to you
thanks for taking the time to explain
all the cool things that you can do with
claw machine learning engine there's a
fourth time I say thank you I'm still
having issues the engine part of it I
I knew a lot about tensorflow like I've
been watching some of the talks that we
said that Martin garner gave a cloud
next amazing talks and it was a very
interesting thing to add a little bit of
a like ok so on top of that what is
cloud machine learning engine absolutely
totally agreed I don't get to devil very
much with the ml stuff so super happy to
have you thanked on to help educate us
and talk to us all about the whole
platform well so I think it's time to go
to our question of the week yeah so I
think this is it an interesting one and
I think probably right up your alley so
uh when talking about like rest
endpoints often I hear about these
things called API keys so what are a p
i-- keys and how can i use them on cloud
endpoints like what would i want to use
them for and why would i use them okay
so the first part of the question is
what is an api key an api key is like a
key that you use to authorize some api
call and the important thing is that
this authorization not really
authentication this these are not really
secure you should not use them as a
security measure really because they're
actually kind of easy to intercept
once they're intercepted they are they
do not have any expired
expiration time so you know it's like
once you have it you have it forever
unless it's of course ban which means
that for some things they're very useful
because they're very easy to use
basically in general you just ask them
add them as a ammeter to a query like
very often you will see them on the URL
they can be very useful for service to
service authentication for instance
specifically when one of the services
not really behaving in the name of a
user but just as a project right you
have a project acting as a project
itself that is one of the ways to do it
very simple to do and especially when
you actually trust the whole chain and
is a chain like over HTTP or something
we're basically the the content is not
shown to everyone looking the other
option is to use authentication tokens
right which is off to stuff like that
which is way more advanced but also it's
harder to maintain at
two years like I don't know if you've
implemented off to dance on our server
now it is not fun it is real fun it is
the kind of thing that make you love
fire based authentication stuff like
that really
so when to use API keys well the answer
is pretty simple the answer is whenever
you authenticating a project not a user
right cookies you don't want to have a
an API key per user it's per project per
group of like an app for instance if you
have an mobile app you might want to use
an API key there and also when you're
able to make sure that that is actually
hidden enough or secured enough that
people will know able to find it easily
and no matter when you're using it API
key those API keys should never be the
only security measure that you have all
right cool
so it sounds like API keys are just a
nice light way to give people access to
your API eyes but also be able to
determine who is accessing your API eyes
and like on what of behalf they are
accessing your api's yeah basically so
if you if you want to control like
security like hardcore security it's not
the way to do it but if you want to
control things like quotas or basically
having a better way of tracking who is
using what something that you can grab
them the logs and stuff like that API
keys are great for that excellent and so
cloud endpoints they give you an easy
way to set up API keys is that right oh
yes it's super simple so the cool thing
is that basically you can once you
deploy a Cloud endpoints API on your
project then only the API key is created
from a project that have access to that
API are valid which means that then what
you can do is you create your API you
deploy it and then you create as many
API keys as you want from your project
directly and then you can share those
which is very simple or even better you
share your API with whoever you want to
give access to your API then they
activate their API or their project like
you would activate any other API like
let's say compute engine or kubernetes
like sorry kubernetes container engine
all of those are different api's just go
to the API manager you activate it and
then you can create a new API from that
project directly
basically you're able to expose an API
as if you were Google basically and
anyone that has access to that API can
create an API key and get direct access
to your API cool sounds great
I can't wait to get started with API
keys great so I think it's time to
finish the episode but before we say
goodbye you are right now in Canada what
are you up to and what are you up to
after so I'm in Canada by the time this
episode airs I will have already spoken
at the unity meet up but I will be doing
the polyglot to Vancouver meetup the day
after so we talk about G R PC and
kubernetes after that I am doing an East
Coast game conference and then vector
conference talking about gaming stuff
with kubernetes shortly after that I
want to highlight doing a game jam for
play crafting with extra life so it's a
two weekend special event to help run a
tease money for UCSF Children's
Hospitals so nice it's going to be on
May 5th and 7th here in San Francisco
the URL will be in the show notes what
are you up to I'm basically on my way to
China I'm living next week for go for
called China in Shanghai it's going to
be pretty amazing I'm gonna be also
organizing a couple meetups then after
that I will be in New York and I
actually got confirmed that I will be
speaking at the Google developer group
meetup in New York we've our dear friend
Brett nice yeah we're gonna be having a
serverless Meetup he will be talking
about cloud functions and I will be
talking about cloud endpoints excellent
and go obviously obviously and and then
on May 15th we actually have a pretty
big event here in San Francisco it's a
gopher fest 2017 so it's gonna be a lot
of really cool go talks and we're gonna
be hosting it the launch pad here near
near the Google's office in San
Francisco will have a link in the show
notes so you can RSVP I'm pretty sure
the RSVP list is going to go full really
fast so if you're interested in it go
find it right now sounds good let me
know if you can get me a spot maybe I'll
come along yeah I don't think so
okay awesome Fran says thank you so much
for yet another week and yet another
wonderful episode thank you so much mark
and have lots of fun in Canada I will
and we'll see you all next week
see y'all next week
[Music]
you